well breaking right now new york
officials have just wrapped up a press
conference following a shooting at a
brooklyn subway station at the height of
rush hour this morning at least 10
people were shot 28 people are at a
local hospital five of them are in
critical condition they still do not
have a suspect in custody however they
did name a person of interest elise
preston reports from brooklyn new york
terrified commuters poured out of a new
york city subway train as it pulled into
this brooklyn station moments after a
gunman set off a smoke canister inside
he then opened fire striking multiple
people on the subway
and in the platform police say a male
suspect who was last seen wearing a
green construction vest and a gas mask
hit several people before getting away
they had no
caring about the individuals that they
assaulted
as they simply went about their daily
lives this 15-year-old was on the train
headed to school i didn't know what to
do i didn't know i just got off the
train
i stayed by some police officers john
ramsey who lives in the neighborhood saw
people fleeing the station some of them
injured i'm mystified as to who would
want to hit this area
residents here in new york city have
seen a rise in gun violence and overall
crime during the pandemic good
samaritans sprung into action to help
those who were hurt we saw new yorkers
in a difficult situation an emergency
helping each other that's the subway
riders that's who new yorkers are new
york city mayor eric adams who's working
from home after testing positive for
covid released a video statement we
would not allow new yorkers to be
terrorized even by a single individual a
law enforcement official tells cbs news
authorities have not ruled out terrorism
as a motive as they search for the
suspect elise preston cbs news new york